what makes Society run okay no no wait
wait wait wait wait let me let me let me
I need you I remember remember M your
mic again all right this is your final
warning one more time you're going to go
okay ladies I don't think me like I'm
sorry okay thank you it's very important
all right thank you your gu all right
all right wait what did you say it
respect your guest okay actually you can
go now thank you goodbye yeah goodbye um
Security will escort you out yeah that's
pretty yeah I've warned you like three
times to to what to stop over talking me
we read you the rules at the beginning
of the show it's all right go ahead
everyone talking each other no all right
and now you're going to keep talking
back goodbye goodbye go please wow
please exclude my conversation and
everything from this video no it's live
so I'll see
you oh my gosh it's very impolite of you
you didn't invite me to take me out I
didn't want to yeah but